pour le public mango fils ce sont trois
hectares de jeu et de tyrolienne pour le
personnel c'est surtout une infinité de
détail a passé en revue des kilomètres
de câbles d'aménagement en bois laissé
sans soins pendant plus de trois mois
certains arbres sont désormais à
l'étroit dans leur plate-forme la zone
tropicale donc la majorité des arbres
grandissent très vite ici l'autre
problème que l'on va rencontrer c'est la
chaleur et la sécheresse qui a fait
travailler les bois donc forcément sur
nos plateformes derrière nous quand on
attrape l'arbre pour accrocher une eau
plate fin ça va se déformer si on n'est
pas là pour et grandir la plateforme on
va étouffer l'arbre et on a un risque
fragilité sur l'arbre une plateforme
dure six ou sept ans et un système de
boulons sur tige filetée permet
régulièrement des cartes et les planches
pour laisser le tronc grandir après
trois mois son intervention il faudra
parfois cassé et refaire pour la
sécurité du public comme la santé des
arbres
l'une des tâches les plus minutieuses et
la vérification des tyroliennes un câble
abîmés ou desserrer serait un danger je
changer le sort table qu'ils sont
qui sont oubliés c'est ce qu'ils ont
fait ce qu'ils soient en gros c'est
quelque chose que tu fais avec beaucoup
de beaucoup de précision d'attention
comme il faut il faut comme on aime à
vue comme une personne entre nous donc
il faut montrer vigilants que tu es très
minutieux 1,6 cm ça peut faire toute la
différence pour le retour du public
samedi
l'équipe a beaucoup élaguer les branches
dangereuse évacuer les feuilles mortes
nettoyez bien que l'on soit en plein air
de nombreuses mesures de précaution vont
s'imposer
on a juste un changement qui va être un
petit peu différent pour nos clients
c'est qu'on va prendre des groupes
maximum de 10 personnes à la fois et on
sera dorénavant plus qu'une personne sur
la plate forme alors qu'avant on pouvait
être jusqu'à trois donc la capacité du
parc va être de 60 clients parcours
avant pouvait prendre jusqu'à 140 voire
150 clients en même temps maintenant on
va être sur une base de 50 personnes à
la fois c'est pas les mêmes revenus
c'est beaucoup d'investissement
également pour désinfecter les matériels
depuis quelques jours beaucoup de
familles se présentent déjà à la
recherche d'activités pour à la sortie
du confinement on essaie de reprendre un
petit peu de temps à l'extérieur sur
pour surtout pour les enfants leur faire
profiter un petit peu du temps avant la
période cyclonique vont avoir beaucoup
de plus donc on est venu malheureusement
le site est fermé mais avec la petite
doudou on va revenir plus tard mon beau
fils 17 ans d'existence cette année
avait encore assez trésorerie pour payer
ses six salaire mais la fréquentation
pendant les grandes vacances sera
crucial pour l'avenir juillet août
représentent près de la moitié du
chiffre d'affaires annuel